hey you guys flickers of fear time once
again and uh we're continuing with our
folk horror february now this movie
right here is one that i have had
multiple requests to do i've actually
seen this a couple of times previously
and i watched it a third time for this
review
this is the 2013
british film
a field in england
now
as i said this has been on my list for a
really long time this movie is
weird but i mean that in a good way
though so i do kind of feel like if
and i wouldn't even it is a horror movie
but not really in
kind of the normal sense of the word i'm
not even really sure what category i
would put it in
uh it's in black and white it's very
arty
it's very trippy
it's very
open to interpretation
uh there's a lot of stuff going on in
there that is absolutely not explained
that you really kind of have to
maybe know some historical context or
maybe know something about some
particular
uh occult
symbology things like that some
particular folklore to really get the
most out of it but that said the more
times i see this movie the more i enjoy
it the more layers i see in it again
just like most of the movies that i have
been covering on the series it's really
not for everybody but
i actually really dig it and like i said
i've seen it you know i saw it three
times so i the third time i saw it
yesterday and you just pick up like more
every single time and i'm not saying
that the interpretation if you want to
call it that that i have for this movie
is the correct one and i don't even
think there is necessarily a correct
interpretation of this because there you
can read it in a couple of different
ways i will kind of tell you what i kind
of think it's leaning toward but
you know what i think about it is
probably just as valid as what other
people think about it because i have
seen a couple other interpretations of
it as well
so this was the fourth film directed by
ben wheatley i've also
covered one of his other movies kill
list
which is also a fantastic film although
in many ways completely different to
this which to me that's like a mark of a
really good director he's worked in
you know several different
genres and seems to like kick ass in all
of them which is you know really
difficult to do i mean most directors
kind of have their wheelhouse and they
kind of work within that and there's
nothing wrong with that i mean there's
nothing wrong to like playing to your
strengths or liking a particular genre
more than others and wanting to work in
that but the fact that he's made four
very very different films and uh they've
all been excellent and worth watching is
you know really to me very admirable
so uh kill list and this the really the
only things they have in common is uh
the presence of michael smiley in uh the
actor in a major role uh he's in both of
them and the uh folk horror element now
a field in england is much more a
full-on folk horror movie whereas kill
list really is kind of like more like a
crime thriller with some folk horror
elements that don't get introduced till
the third act but this one is much more
uh much more folk horror in the sense
that it's based around it's even like
set uh you know in the past in the 17th
century and based around uh occult
practices and alchemy and things like
that interestingly too i actually didn't
know this until i was researching the
movie but this movie is significant it
came out in uh 2013 summer of 2013 and
was as far as i'm aware the first film
to be released simultaneously
in uh movie theaters
uh on dvd blu-ray
also on film four like on free tv in the
uk
and also on video on demand so it was
released on all four platforms like in
all four formats on the same exact day
which i thought was pretty cool but i'm
pretty sure this was the first movie uh
to do that uh another fun fact i saw
this on wikipedia when this movie came
out i guess some of the theaters or
whatever that was showing it or you know
some pubs nearby uh they had like a
a beer that was tied into this movie
and the tagline of it was open up and
let the devil in which is one of
which is a line that's repeated in the
movie so i thought that was pretty cute
i wonder if you can still get hold of
that i doubt it i think it was like
limited edition
so this film as i said it's set in uh
during the english civil war i don't
think they tell you the specific year
but it's somewhere you know in the 1640s
right around there and they also don't
tell you exactly where the location is
they do mention some locations that oh
that's really far or whatever but they
don't really tell you where this is
specifically because one thing that i
will say about this movie is that
i don't know
or i don't think that we're supposed to
i kind of see it in the same way that
you see something like i don't know
maybe like waiting for godot or
something like that where it's just kind
of like in this space but it's in like
this weird like liminal space which is
not necessarily akin to a real space but
it's just kind of like this little
place where everybody kind of comes
together and you know bigger themes are
uh kind of manifested i guess like
within this one place so it doesn't
really matter where this field is
specifically
so as i said it's the english civil war
and uh our main character is a guy named
whitehead who's played by rhys
shearsmith and it's interesting he's in
uh the league of gentlemen i think and i
saw his picture on wikipedia or imdb or
whatever
and he is like the picture of him that's
on wikipedia
is he's like unrecognizable like in this
movie because he looks like you know
from the 17th century he's got like
really long hair he's real grubby and
stuff like that although he's like more
of like he's not a gentleman but he's
kind of more
uh has more social standing than some of
the other guys so he is like dressed a
little bit nicer so whitehead we learn
uh i will say too that as i said there's
not a lot of exposition in this the
characters don't have much backstory ben
wheatley said that was done on purpose
although i will say he wrote this with
um amy jump who is his uh wife and
collaborator they pretty much always
collaborate on movies together uh she
wrote the screenplay for this
i kind of feel like some of his other
stuff was more improvisational like
where he worked with the actors and i
think he did that a bit here too but the
script here is quite different from
kill lists i feel like would kind of had
a more improvisational kind of feel in
the sense that they wrote the
screenplay uh out of the characters you
know what i mean like they worked with
the characters and they kind of like
developed uh what was gonna happen like
in the plot from there whereas this one
i feel like uh the script was more or
less the way they wanted it and then
we're just seeing the actors
interpretation of it i could be wrong
about that but that was the impression
that i got so yeah so like i said uh ben
wheatley has said that he doesn't like
in movies when things are over explained
or uh if there's exposition he's like i
basically wanted this movie to feel like
you just got dropped in the middle of
the 17th century the english civil war
you got dropped into this situation and
you're just having to like figure out
what's going on from context clues
because why would these people be
explaining to one another like what was
going on because everybody already knows
so that's kind of what so you really do
have to pay attention to a lot of the
dialogue and symbolism and stuff like
that it's one of those kind of movies if
you kind of want the whole experience of
it
so whitehead we learn
is an assistant to an alchemist
now at the very beginning of the movie
he seems to be like uh fleeing or
escaping from this guy named commander
trower who
i'm guessing is like trying to kill him
or you know he didn't do what he was
supposed to do or whatever
uh it's also established very early on
that whitehead is a self-professed
coward i mean he's not a soldier uh he's
out here on some other mission which you
don't actually find out until later on
and uh you know he's not he doesn't want
to be in the middle of this he doesn't
know how to use a weapon or anything
like that
so uh it turns out that he's fleeing
from this commander the commander gets
wounded uh during a battle and then
there's this other guy who comes along
named cutler who actually finishes
trower off
so at this point cutler is with two
other guys whose names are jacob and
friend friend is kind of like he's
actually the source of most of the
because this does have a dark comedic
element to it actually maybe not even
dark comedy maybe just like a comedic
element just in this and friend uh who
is
kind of an idiot but a lovable idiot
sort of he's he's the full character he
most of the [ __ ] that's funny like comes
from him you know what i mean like at
some point whitehead is explaining to
him like what an alchemist does and what
astrology is and saying like how we you
know we do divination like based on the
planets and the stars and friend is just
looking at him like nope not following
what those are you know what i mean and
it's just like it's just great like his
uh his facial expression and just the
way he was just like nope i don't i
don't know what you're talking about
it's just like [ __ ] crack me up
but yeah so uh so here's cutler he's
killed the commander and he's with the
two other guys jacob and friend and he's
basically like look uh we're kind of
sick of this whole battle [ __ ] this
whole civil war we heard there was an
ale house nearby and we're just gonna go
dessert and uh we're just gonna go there
and get drunk and get some hookers and
you know [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
so basically the four these four
unlikely people
join up together and they end up in this
field uh while the battle presumably uh
moves away from them so again uh you're
with whitehead who is not a soldier with
these three soldiers who have decided to
desert because they think nobody will
notice and they're just like we don't
have any stake in this or whatever
so while they're in this field uh at
first it seems fairly straightforward
you kind of get to know a few of them
and stuff like that but then
weird [ __ ] starts to happen
at some point they cross into this big
ring of mushrooms now if you know
anything about english folklore that's
called a fairy ring so we're led to
assume at least i was led to assume that
whatever happens inside of this mushroom
ring is maybe not reality maybe it's
perceptual maybe they're in another
dimension maybe it's just kind of like
this liminal space where you know space
and time are not the same as like
outside of it so they're kind of in some
other place is what i'm getting at
uh there's also a thing too where
cutler makes a stew
out of
presumably magic mushrooms and the other
people start to hallucinate now
interestingly whitehead uh because he's
an alchemist and he's in the middle of
some mission or whatever he's been
fasting so he does not take it uh he
doesn't take the mushrooms but the other
ones do
now as they're going along they find
a very weird thing
they find this
pole
that's uh like carved with all these
little figures and stuff and it's like
in the middle of this field
and tied to it is a rope
and they're all pulling on the rope but
they can't um you know they can't get
whatever it is that's at the end of this
rope to come to them even though all
four of them are pulling it
so they go to where the end of the rope
is and it turns out at the end of the
rope there's a guy
like four guys gonna like pull him
this is o'neill
now it turns out that o'neill was
actually the guy that whitehead had been
sent out to
apprehend because o'neill
was supposedly also an apprentice or an
assistant to the same alchemist the same
master that white had had
and o'neill has allegedly stolen a whole
bunch of papers belonging to said
alchemist and so whitehead has been sent
to procure them to get them back and to
bring um
o'neill into custody
o'neal though is kind of like he's
called the devil many times
uh and it could be that he might be like
a stand-in for the devil he is for sure
very sociopathic he is very cold-blooded
he kind of like he's he's a contrast
even though he and whitehead i think are
mirrors of the same person and i'll get
into why i think that later
but
he's kind of like everything that
whitehead is not whitehead is very
cowardly he's very naive um he's spent
his entire life in books he doesn't
really know anything about the wider
world um he doesn't know anything about
any other people or women or anything
like that you know oh and his big uh his
big hobby is lace making that was a new
skill that he learned and he was very
proud of uh saying that but uh so but
you know by contrast o'neill is just
this very very worldly very
as i said sociopathic you know uh
cold-blooded he just wants what he wants
and he's just gonna like do whatever it
takes to get it
so even though whitehead uh tries to
arrest o'neill
that's really not working out because
like i said he's kind of like a pat more
of a passive person whereas o'neil is
very domineering and he's basically no
no no it's like i'm taking over this
[ __ ] and so not only does he do that but
he also
kind of presses the other guys into
service
to he says that you know i've i've had
this camp out here for a while um
there's treasure out here and you guys
are going to find it for me and like dig
for it
so he basically like presses them into
service but you're led to believe maybe
by putting some kind of spell on them
now one thing that he does say he has a
conversation with whitehead where he
says i ignore he says even though i hate
you personally whitehead he's like i
acknowledge that there are some things
that you are better at than i am so i'm
gonna need your expertise in this area
because apparently some of his alchemy
is lacking because of the personality
traits that he lacks that uh that
whitehead has
now there's this one great scene uh
midway and a lot of people talk about
this scene when they talk about a field
in england because it's really
unsettling just like the way it's shot
o'neil they get to their k to the camp
his camp and o'neill takes whitehead
into his tent
you don't see what happens
but you hear
this blood curdling screaming like
whitehead screaming so you're presuming
that he's being tortured it's not shown
but you can imagine it and it's pretty
unsettling and then so that goes on for
like a couple of minutes
and then
this really creepy [ __ ]
whitehead comes out of the tent
with like a rope tied around his
midsection and like the rope like behind
him as though someone's kind of like
leaning about and the look on his he
just looks completely
crazed possessed
something he has like this really weird
like richtest of like in his eyes a
little bit and it's like really really
freaky and it's done in like slow motion
so what you're lead to assume is that
o'neill
has used his alchemy powers you know his
magic occult powers to essentially
turn whitehead into a divining rod to
help him find this treasure that he's
presumably looking for
so that's kind of how the rest of it
goes and like i said it's fairly
straightforward for maybe the first
third i want to say of the movie and
then once they find that um that post
that o'neill is tied to then it gets
trippy and weird and i mean that in the
in the you know in the literal sense
where
you know they've they're all tripping on
magic mushrooms like [ __ ] stars oh and
another thing too and they have actually
a warning at the beginning of the movie
if you are an epileptic or you can't
like watch flashing images
i would not recommend watching this
movie because there is one point later
on when everybody's just like tripping
balls
and there's just all these like flashing
like kind of and uh mirroring kind of
shots and they're really really cool but
yeah i can see how if you had problems
with that you might not want to watch
that because it is like very flashy and
it goes on for like several minutes just
so yeah so at this point you know
they're trying to find the treasure some
of them
get killed in this in the uh you know
pursuit of that but then like friend
gets killed for example but then like
later on he resurrects somehow like he's
alive again which is weird because that
happened like right near the beginning
too like when whitehead first came out
of the you know bushes like right at the
very beginning of the film and friend
was laying there and everyone presumed
he was dead but as soon as everybody
started talking about oh we're gonna
find the ale house you know he sits up
and says oh did somebody say ale you
know what i mean so that's why i'm
saying like him being the source of like
all the funny [ __ ] in the movie
but yeah so again this movie very very
trippy uh one there is no
treasure not the way you're thinking and
pretty much i don't really want to spoil
the ending but i do want to kind of say
i do want to kind of say what i kind of
think is going on now i have seen
interpretations
that the field
in this movie is essentially like a
purgatory
i have seen um interpretations that said
that all of the people
in it are not real necessarily but are
all just like manifestations of
different parts of whitehead's
personality i guess uh and it's like
some kind of judgment which is kind of
closer uh to what i think there is a lot
of um occult and alchemical symbols
there's a scrying mirror there's all
kind of like alchemical
symbology
so to me what i think is going on is
that i think whitehead
i'm not sure if he's the only actual
character i'm not even sure if it
actually matters
i read it
as whitehead's journey
uh you know it's like an occult like a
magical journey i kind of felt like that
and i kind of felt that o'neill
was again like the mirror image of him
but he was like a bad guy but he had all
the bad traits
and um you know whitehead had all the
good traits but he needed some of the
bad traits that o'neill had to make
himself a complete person or a complete
alchemist or his own man because that
was a lot of um some stuff that was
going on too was that
he was an assistant to an alchemist you
never see the alchemist they were
talking about or anything like that he
just calls him his master
but um so he's just the assistant and
he's very servile you know he's very
passive in that regard uh you know
calling the dude master and everything
like that but as the movie goes on and
not and it's not just him but there's
other characters that say this too
about how
you know they they want to be out of
servitude they want to be their own man
because they're tying
i think he's tying the journey of this
man
in with the larger
context of the english civil war which
was kind of like you know it was like
the royalists and
uh parliamentarians or whatever i can't
remember what it was but um basically it
was a very very it was kind of like
seems like do we want a monarchy do we
want like a more democratic kind of
thing going on and there were gonna be
like all these changes heralded in
culture not only in britain but in kind
of the world at large because they were
kind of among the first countries to do
that
so
he's making kind of like a parallel
between
what happened during the english civil
war all of these
soldiers like going to die for these
much bigger
uh you know themes or much bigger ideas
uh that maybe they didn't even
understand and being kind of like you
know a servant in that regard and i
think that he's tying that into like a
bigger thing of one man being a servant
to an alchemist and finding his own way
and to do that he has to embrace both
the good and the bad because i do think
that o'neill
whether he was a real person or not i
think that he represented
essentially the devil but he represented
you know the alchemical there's
everything you know everything evil
whereas whitehead was like everything
good he was pure but he still wasn't a
complete person you know what i mean so
he had to take in and i think that's
with that line that was repeated a few
times throughout the movie like open up
and let the devil in i think that's what
that meant i think that to become a
complete person he had to take on some
of the quote unquote evil attributes of
his
rival there's also a thing too there's
also because they're like i said there's
a lot of alchemical uh and magical
symbolism but there's also like some
christian symbolism too you know there's
one thing it's like there's a whole
black sun thing there's uh i kind of
feel like the last scene where
uh where whitehead is standing there
wearing o'neill's clothes and jacob and
friend are there who have been killed
earlier but then they come back it's
almost like a trinity type of thing
because those two characters were more
on the good side whereas cutler was
actually working for o'neill so cutler
was kind of more on the bad side so he
doesn't get to come back so like him and
so it almost seemed like him and o'neil
were like damned but the other two were
redeemable like whitehead and the other
two guys jacob and friend were
redeemable because they were more good
than bad uh so they were the ones that
got out of
whatever this purgatorial liminal
you know fairy ring type situation was
as i said though you can read it as like
a purgatory and all of these people are
their own people and they're all just
trying to get out of their own personal
purgatory but personally i read it as
whitehead's journey
from
naivete
servitude to
knowledge and enlightenment and the fact
that he
takes on you know some of the
quote-unquote evil that o'neal had by
you know putting on his clothes and you
know
so he becomes like a whole person and
then he like has his henchmen with him
or whatever uh but that's kind of how i
read it i just kind of read it as more
like a
you know toward a toward enlightenment
type of uh narrative but as i said there
are multiple multiple interpretations of
this um i've seen like i've i'm just a
cursory like reading through some stuff
and like watching a few documentaries
about it there were like three or four
different ones
so you can pretty much like bring your
own thing to it i mean i do think that
ben wheatley like i said did have
obviously wanted to make parallels
between
uh these people's journey these people's
experience and the larger english civil
war going on so he's making parallels
there but because he used so much occult
and alchemical symbolism so much
folklore like with the fairy ring with
the mushrooms and he was also really
interested in um 17th century use of
hallucinogens which apparently they did
uh him and his wife amy jump who wrote
the screenplay they did actually do a
really lot of uh research about that and
he said there were times where they
would like take the magic mushrooms and
like grind them in a dust and like blow
them in people's faces and like do magic
tricks and stuff like that so it was
very much part of the religious and the
magical uh you know toolbox i guess at
the time so he got very very interested
in that so there's definitely a lot of
that in it so as i said this is not a
regular ass horror movie i'm not even
sure i don't even know what genre i
would call this it for real does have
horror elements it does have some pretty
gruesome
uh wounds like uh you know o'neill
getting his face shot off and stuff like
that and getting his leg shot in half
and stuff so there is like some gruesome
[ __ ] in it um it's almost kind of like a
strange
i don't know it has horror elements but
then it's just kind of like this
surrealist nightmarish
you know historical
allegory
something it's just you know it's just
really really hard to describe unless
you've actually seen it again very very
trippy there's a lot of
psychedelic uh kind of imagery but
uh but not it's over the top because
it's in black and white and like i said
the cinematography on this is really
beautiful like the black and white is
just really really beautiful and really
luminous i wanted to say too that he
also makes some interesting use of of
tableaus uh in the sense that you know
the film is going but then the people
are like still like standing still
sort of like reenacting
you know this is like a still from this
scene that's gonna happen which doesn't
get used a lot in films it has been used
in films before uh but you don't see it
that often and i think it really lends
a kind of
there's just really something very very
compelling and like very very unsettling
about this film you know what i mean a
lot of it is the imagery the imagery is
just
slightly askew and it just makes it very
unsettling uh also the score uh helps a
lot on that
this is just a really really strange
film some people are just gonna hate it
and think it's boring and like or it
doesn't make any sense i get that um but
honestly the more times you see it like
the more
you pick out like the more layers you
pick out of it's definitely one where
you know every line of dialogue has like
some bigger meaning or something like
that so it's it's almost i almost want
to say it's kind of like existentialist
in a way you know what i mean like i
said in the same way that uh you know
like waiting for godot or something like
that um not quite as spare as that but i
think it's like along the same lines uh
but yeah so again this was a movie that
i had been wanting to cover for a long
time and i thought folk horror february
is a good time to do it because this
actually has been requested uh multiple
times so i finally got around to it so
hopefully i did it justice um if you've
seen it let me know what you thought
about it in the comments let me know
what uh your interpretation of it was
because i know there are several and i
am absolutely not convinced that mine is
the correct one if indeed there even is
a correct one which i probably don't
think there is because this is a very
subjective film and could mean a lot of
things to different people uh you can
get this i'm pretty sure this is on
pretty commonly on most uh streaming
services i actually watched it on
shutter
but i think you can see it on amazon
prime and various other places as well
and i think you can rent it on youtube
too uh so if you haven't seen it go
check it out and let me know what you
think and if you have seen it let me
know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear continuing on with
folklore february and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye